[Musica]
allora tornare a crederci tornare a
crederci per cullberg esattamente dieci
anni fa mi hanno contattato e danesi che
sono i proprietari in questa fondazione
che proprietà di questa azienda
mi hanno detto noi ci crediamo più
quindi vai e chiudi non abbiamo altro
modo che uscire da questo territorio
perché l'italia sono anni che perdiamo
un sacco di patrini quindi di tornare a
crederci era un tema delicatissimo di
un'azienda che era con 1.400 persone
abbondanti 1420 persone che lavoravano
non solo varese ovviamente non sta in
tutta italia ed era sostanzialmente
un'azienda con un piede
alla fine quindi il tema principale che
avevo era far tornare a credere le
persone che lavoravano all'interno
dell'azienda
come potete capire questo era comunque
qualcosa che l'avevano capiti in tante
in tante persone essendo a varese
essendo io un appassionato di
pallacanestro ho detto bisogna citare
qualcuno che evidentemente a che fare
con la città né sesso
michael jordan che è un grandissimo
giocatore di pallacanestro dice possa
accettare di fallire
chiunque fallisce in qualcosa ha detto
da un giocatore che ho visto
personalmente sicuro quando viveva
sigaro a giocare questo concetto del
fallire è un elemento forte perché gli
fallire è sostanzialmente la prendere io
aprendo molto di più dagli sbagli che
faccio dalle cose giuste che facciano le
cose giuste che faccio sono scontate gli
errori mi aprono la mente e dicono e
ragazze fermo ho fatto un errore devo
per forza di cose rifarlo ecco una
società come o rieditato io era
terrorizzata di fare qualsiasi azione
anche perché vedete mette aveva una
storia di fallimenti costanti quindi le
persone erano bloccate nel loro processo
di sviluppo della società
l'altro aspetto
che il sentimento comune ognuno di noi
poteva fare la differenza ma in qualche
modo tutti erano anche qui in una
situazione psicologica tale per cui
tutti si aspettavano che c'era qualcun
altro che dovesse fare il lavoro per
loro quindi c'era la propria la
sensazione dell aspetto qualcuno mi dica
cosa devo fare no quindi nessuno si pone
ma nel modo di nel modo corretto
quindi in realtà l'aspetto quando io
sono arrivato
questa è un'azienda che aveva
esattamente 130 anni di storia
quest'anno facciamo i 140 e ho detto la
signora 130 anni di storia non sono un
patrimonio straordinario quindi qui
dentro c'è un valore incredibile c'è un
valore nella storia dei prodotti c'è un
valore delle persone che è che al
lavorano qui dentro
quindi probabilmente quello che non
riusciamo a fare aprire gli occhi
dobbiamo guardare dobbiamo vedere
dobbiamo capire le cose che possono
funzionare e io avevo un vantaggio
rispetto agli altri anche solo più bello
più intelligente più capace e che io
sono arrivato e non conoscevo questa
storia uno che libera son fatte a
raccontare e sono andato a proprio a
capire la storia di angelo poretti
dall'inizio pd era o non partiamo
dall'inizio partiamo da quando lui ha
fondato sull società per capire qual è
la vera qual era il patrimonio che
avevamo e l'altra cosa che non capivo
neanche diete di birra grandissimo
vantaggio un bevitore di vino adesso
solo un convertito ovviamente ma
all'inizio io capivo anche molto poco
della birra e questo è stato un altro
vantaggio perché in realtà
guardavo aprivo gli occhi in un modo che
nessuno dei dipendenti della nostra
società riuscivo ad avere questo è un
esempio
l'esempio di cosa vuol dire aprire gli
occhi questo è una luce è un gioco a
questa è una lampada questi solo dei
fusti di piedi solo dai fusti che giusto
per farvi capire qui dentro
noi mettiamo 20 litri di prodotto quando
io sono arrivato io non ho inventato
nulla
c'era un manifesto gigantesco
all'ingresso di quelle scale capito le
mattine devo subito questo manifesto
grosso con un frigorifero è uno di
questi fusti pieni di birra
ogni volta che parlavo dicevano le
persone mi dicevano i fusti d'acciaio
sono vecchi la qualità del prodotto non
funziona è difficile perché amo i fusti
ce li rubano ogni fusto vale 60 euro era
uno delle ragioni per cui la società
stava perdendo una montagna di denaro
io questa loro sulle scale alla decima
volta che sono lì li ho guardati liscate
malizia la foto della soluzione
e questo riguarda la comece la sua
soluzione mi state dicendo che i fusti
non vanno ecc ma ha fatto li salviamo
già mamma di venezia t200 sul loro
ultimo terrà verso tutti scoppiati a
ridere ma tutto il mondo lavora con i
fusti da chang ma è tutto il mondo
lavora con queste d'acciaio e noi
lavoreremo con questo banalissimo gioco
e noi trasferirono la birra qui dentro
la scelta completamente matto non esiste
non esiste al mondo nessuno che aveva
fatto un'operazione di questo genere
come lo facciamo noi
oggi a distanza di dieci anni siamo
ormai al 95 per cento di sostituzione
con un tasso di crescita incredibile ma
non solo questa tecnologia che ripeto
non è stata inventata ma è stata
sviluppata da noi questa tecnologia la
stiamo esportando siano dettati centro
di eccellenza mondiale asta molto
esportando in giro per tutto il mondo
questo sarà il futuro della
distribuzione della birra per tanti
motivi 1 per la qualità il prodotto che
noi beviamo dar via raspina acqua e 10
volte migliore di qualsiasi altro
prodotto dei furti anche perché il fusto
benedetto la co2 quindi prodotto in
qualche modo si ossida in pochi giorni
ossidato quindi ha qualità di un
prodotto in fusto e comunque perdente
l'altro e per la sostenibilità
ambientale
noi in questi 300 grammi trasportiamo
dei prodotti in giro per tutta italia
nei furti abbiamo dieci chili pensate
solo l'importo l'impatto di co2
dall'atmosfera di portare dei fusti da
qua a trapani da tra prendi di portarli
indietro vedo ci vuole più tanti altri
effetti collaterali
quindi questo quando prima dicevo aprire
gli occhi e che questo c'era tanto per
fare un esempio delle cose che avevamo
non è che non è stato
nessuna che invitato niente questo era
qualcosa che avevamo già presente
peccato che la gente rideva invece di
sviluppare il progetto paura ecco questo
è una paura notte nella gente ha paura
primo la paura è un bel sentimento e io
ne ho avuta tanta perché quando si hanno
responsabilità ai 1.400 persone
9 dic se sbagliavo in realtà andavano a
casa 1400 persone quindi se non c'è
paura non abbiamo paura di aver paura
scusate il gioco di parole è giusto aver
paura è giusto è un sentimento che
dobbiamo avere
quando facciamo i cambiamenti perché
evidentemente ci prepariamo anche dover
gestire le politiche un lemi che nascano
dalla paura non deve essere bloccante
non è perché ho paura di sbagliare che
non faccia e torniamo al punto di prima
dobbiamo avere il coraggio di poter
fallire il fai un errore tornare
indietro
lo dico sempre le persone che sono
intorno a me voi avete un grande
vantaggio poi potete sbagliare quanto
volete perché tanto chi si assume la
responsabilità dell'errore solo io
quindi sbagliate quello che volete ma
non potete stare fermi
non potete essere bloccati dalla paura
dopodiché se l'errore che faccio troppo
grande e sostituiscono e avete ancora la
possibilità di sbagliare un'altra volta
sostituiscono me ed è giusto che sia
così peraltro quindi la paura non deve
essere un sentimento che blocca il
processo di cambiamento
questo il nostro cuore produttivo no qui
c'è storia e cioè passato qui si vede la
storia è sotto c'è il futuro
noi abbiamo delle tecnologie
straordinarie all'interno di questo di
questo di questo stabilimento perché è
diventato uno dei punti di riferimento a
livello i mondiali del tutte le
tecnologie nuove vengono prima testate
nel nostro stabilimento e poi diventano
patrimonio
a livello complessivo e questo è l'altro
esempio avevamo questa birra strepitosa
mamma fino al 2010 birrificio angelo
poretti sostanzialmente lo conoscevate
qua perché siamo a varese lo conosciamo
le peso di varese io personalmente io a
milano non lontanissimo
non sapevo neanche dell'esistenza di
questo marchio è la prima paura pd paura
ce n'erano tante i nostri competitor
hanno dei nomi esattamente uguali
reti st peroni progetti lo dicono
inglese perché lì la vicinanza e ancora
maggiorenne o quindi tutti si chiamava
nello stesso modo
come si dice tecnicamente sfortuna 9
avevamo tutte tre imprenditori
completamente diversi tutti i tre con lo
stesso problema
giovanni bianchi osvaldo non l'hanno
tutti con lo stesso dedico nome quindi
era giusto la paura la paura qui era
quella quando io a un certo punto ho
chiesto al mastro birraio 10 che tutti
mi facevano bere la spluga in molti di
noi la conoscevano bella spluga perché
mi fa temere la struggono tutte le birre
buone che facciamo questo la migliore
che facciamo di qualcuno la migliore a
un etichetta blu da candeggina
il prodotto declinano volessimo una
candeggina in un botti letto che era
sembravano per lavare i panni
com'è possibile che è buona mi fanno
ormai me la migliore allora di buddle
ma sti birraio dico scusate spiegati
el'acqua straordinaria viene da a fronte
degli ammalati la valgranda fantastico
aveva ilacqua però insomma la dice forte
ma poi cosa fa i malti ce l'hanno tutti
ma altri sono più o meno simili eviti
per raccontare gli eviterà di fitch e
poi vengono i luppoli ok charlie lupoli
ha baciato la birra già al luppolo però
nella notte riflettono la birra al
luppolo o i luppoli una domanda per me
era uno il luppolo io non ho mai pensato
che ce ne fossero tanti tipi telefono il
nostro mattina su come di aver scusa
cosa vuol dire luppoli eva alberto ii ce
ne sono 3 a 3 1 2 1 ceco uno polacco il
cascade americano fantastico ma poi ce
ne sono altri scorsi in natura ce ne
sono più di 300 3 geologica non siano
250 abbondanti dico a quelli se io voi
domani voglio una birra 4 lupoli e a5
scusa dice sotto i 150 quindi quel
problema c'è nico te ne faccio quanti ne
vuoi perfetto la prima le chiamiamo
birrificio dai progetti 3 lupoli la
gente rideva noi clienti dove sono
andato io personale centrato in
esselunga ancora adesso non la raccolta
questo ritratto gli ho spiegato cosa
stanno facendo la strana ma questo è
matto sono usciti hanno riso per delle
giornate
oggi è così tutti
l'azienda crederci perché la gente poi
non credete una roba banale dire che
della birra ci sono e lupoli e la roba
più banale come di che l'automobile si
alza le ruote e si dice certo che c'ha
le ruote di automobile cosa cosa deve
averci al volante per forza e poi
parleremo quindi le cose più semplici
sono quelle che abbiamo davanti al naso
le cose più semplici su quello che
abbiamo davanti al naso
quindi fallire che la paura di tutti e
nell'azienda ormai nessuno faceva più
niente per non sbagliare più
e quindi l'azienda era bloccata quindi
tutti erano lì a indicare appena 1
spostava la pendice eccolo qua che ha
sbagliato quindi fallire fallire che poi
è apprendere che non è fallire e
apprendere perché se uno sbaglia non
apprende io compreso quindi il
fallimento è il fondamentale per
cambiare la mentalità delle persone
anche di tutti il team è la cosa più
importante è la cosa più importante è
giocare con una squadra e giocare una
squadra e cambiare i posti non ho
cambiato tutte le persone
ho cambiato tante persone che
riportavano a me ma quelli che giocano
oggi sono le persone che ho trovato io
non mi sono portato tanti manager
dall'esterno all'interno per rimpiazzare
gli ho trovati lì perché tal 1400
persone se non ero capace di trovare una
squadra di gente vincente
non ero capace di fare il mio mestiere
tornare così si torna a vincere e oggi
ci credono e ovviamente adesso è tutto
più facile però in qualche modo abbiamo
la possibilità di cambiare abbiamo la
possibilità di fallire
abbiamo la possibilità di tornare a
credici grazie a tutti
[Applauso]